in your new book you talk about the
story method and if I may it's a share
theme one of a kind reflect and yearn
and so the acronym is s-t-o-r-y what is
this and why is it important
I was really trying to find a way to
make it really easy for storytellers to
remember the five important things
um to consider when they're creating
their story
and the first one is
s for story why share this story with
the world why is extremely important in
trying to understand
why uh why tell the story why do people
need need to know it and hear it and
from your perspective as a Storyteller
you have to really understand that and
really know the answer to why you're
sharing the story with the world
T is theme
and for any good story there should be a
theme and this is really what your story
is about
um and when you think about you know
children's books and fables and fairy
tales some of your favorite ones you
might not know it but there is a theme a
recurring theme that occurs throughout
the story and sometimes it's a lesson a
cautionary tale
um it could be something that really
puts a perspective on your life or other
someone else's life but something that
you can reflect upon your own life but
what is what is the story really about
it's not just about the plot of this
happens to this character and this and
this happens in the end but the theme is
really what is this story about
um in the not in the sense of the plot
but in terms of the real meaning behind
it
the oh one of a kind is if you are going
to share the story with the world how is
it unique can you place a Twist upon it
can you set it in a different
environment can you have different
characters can you
tell that story in a different culture
in a different world in a different time
period so that it feels fresh again
because when you think about some of the
really popular stories you know the The
Shakespearean Romeo and Juliet like
there's all these different versions and
ways that you can tell that story so how
can you make it feel fresh and relevant
and unique and one of a kind that's
something that not only just in terms of
like putting a your own perspective or a
Twist on it but perhaps the medium that
you tell that story in can you make it
into uh you know an opera or you know a
a children's book or um you know
changing the tone can you make it into a
mystery rather than a drama all of the
all of these things to really make it
feel One of a Kind R in the story method
is reflect and that's really questioning
why you are the best person to tell that
story and it might not just be you as an
individual if it is your own personal
project yes that is the question that
you should ask but if you're in a team
or you're working for a company or a
client why are they why are the company
the client uh whoever you're working
with why are they the best people
to tell that story and so that
reflection is really holding a mirror up
on yourself the Storyteller the Creator
the one who's going to
um you know share this story with the
world you really have to understand why
you should be the voice for it and to
really and if you are the voice what is
this perspective the unique perspective
that you're sharing with the world
because once you understand that then it
will feel One of a Kind it will feel
authentic it will feel like it's coming
from a genuine Place rather than one
that is contrived or um something that
feels like it's been done before or
something that doesn't feel like it's
anything new or interesting so what is
that different perspective that you can
bring in as a Storyteller and a Creator
to make it feel like there was no one
else in the world who can tell that
story better than you
why in the story method is uh yearn and
that's really about the audience wish
fulfillment and this is something that I
always go back to again and again is
that each one of us you know in our
lives has a deep desire and a fantasy
that we want to fulfill and for one
person it might be to fulfill the desire
of being in a world of vampires and
feeling like you are a creature of the
night another person might be having
this wish fulfillment of like what does
it feel like to be a world famous
musician you know what kind of a
lifestyle can I live by going into that
world some people want to step into a
Fantastical world like Star Wars or
Harry Potter
fictional worlds that are very uh really
expansive and large and you know know
what is that wish fulfillment for your
particular audience member it's all
about understanding and respecting who
your audience is and what you can not
only you know about meeting their
expectations but about meeting that the
exceeding those expectations and really
fulfilling on that guest promise so when
you think about
creating an experience and you know
what to think about what your audience
member what your visitor should would
want to do in this place you always
think back to well what is their wish
fulfillment what is the thing that they
aspire to do what is it that they dream
of doing
um when they think about this world and
this place and that's a really great
place to start
we talked about earlier how you love to
see the element of surprise on the
children's faces I'm sure adult children
as well and it must be very exciting to
see you know the parents that it might
be there for equal reasons because they
want to attend yeah and their element of
surprise yeah because you know all of us
have that inner child within us and I
think that when we create these
immersive stories for children of all
ages to experience including adults and
the adults that never really grew up uh
you know you really have that when you
create that space to give them
permission to be children again to
really let loose and play and engage and
laugh and dance and do all the things
that you can't do in your normal life
adult life I think that we need more of
that we need more opportunities for
people to really play again and to um
fulfill their childlike curiosity and to
have that feeling of being adventurous
again and to really expose yourselves to
Worlds and to people that are unfamiliar
to you I think that when we start living
a life where we're more closed in and
rather than expanding our mindset and
you know exploring the world and meeting
different people and experiencing what
their lives can be like that's something
that I hope to do in a lot of the
stories that I create and whenever I
experience someone else's story I feel
like I want to know more about the
people and the world
that I you know that are that surround
me I feel like that's a way for us to
better understand each other
um to put ourselves in other people's
shoes to really think about
um the world through their eyes and
through their perspectives because only
then can we have compassion for each
other and empathy and only then can we
really have meaningful dialogue and
conversation so
storytelling is a really great way for
people to um
you know connect with each other even
people that you've never met before from
the other side of the world right so
it's a way it's a bridge it's a bridge
from one person to another it's a it's a
way for you to be able to share
something that you
hit that doesn't cost anything really
when you tell a story to someone else
right it's a way that you can reveal a
bit of yourself
um and for them to understand who you
are and where you come from and what
your story is about all of these things
I think it's just
um a really great way for us to connect
more as as a society as a world